yo what's up its River me and I'm back
in my first video I talked to you about
how I took studio time from an idea to
building the MVP and evening launching
it which generated over a million hits
to the site the first thousand dollars
in revenue literally weeks so in this
video I want to talk to you a little bit
more and when I got a lot of questions
about which was how do you take this
initial marketplace MVP and scale it
into being the largest online community
music studio is in the entire world
which it is today and what tools did you
use to help you do that I'm gonna talk
in this video about all those tools and
how I use them together to run studio
time and I also want to mention one
thing and that's a lot of people think
that studio time is a large
venture-backed startup with the big team
behind it in a lot of capital which
equates resources the answer is that
it's not it's actually just right now
and I can effectively run studio time
pretty much from my phone on the go no
matter you know what I'm doing or where
I am so now that you know that is just
me I want to talk to you about these
tools that I use that help me to do that
some of these tools you've probably
heard of their WordPress sharetribe
zapier charge be stripe and slack I'm
gonna talk to you more about how I
effectively use these tools together and
whether to the technical the technology
as much as possible so I didn't have to
really build anything custom for studio
time so first off a lot of people also
are wondering and have commented on my
other video and that is this studio time
built on share tribes open source or
hosted version so there's two different
versions of sharetribe available I'll
link down here to both of them below so
you can check them out yourself but in
short did you guys write em is actually
on share tribes hosted platform now I
could go into the extensive detail
talking about this but to keep it very
brief
I simply and in doing so that way I can
which sharetribe is mainly for the
hosting and support of studio time
anything goes wrong or if there's
anything that you know needs to be done
on the platform then I can simply
contact cher tribes and they can take
care of that since I'm paying them for
their hosted platform so marketplace
solutions now I didn't have to modify
sharetribe to platform to of course to
meet my needs for studio time and
provide for a very customized user
experience on the site now the easy way
to see how I use sharetribe
and then WordPress together that way it
creates more of a customized experience
for users it's just simple look at this
de Maynes so in your browser when you go
to WWSD do x io which is the home page
you will see that that is a very custom
look that is not on other should've
tried marketplaces now the reason why is
that w WV o mio and anything that is on
that domain for instance the /y slash
subscription or the community of artists
producers in engineers and others is
actually on wordpress
so I built custom WordPress pages that I
could easily modify through this kind of
template that I traded and I simply used
different domains and you'll notice the
subdomain those are WWWE tango as I
mentioned but sure tribes is actually
listing stop studio times dot IO so in a
different functionality that is on
sharetribe is actually any of the user
accounts of account creation goes into
the listing creation for studio listings
which then goes into requesting studios
from user to listing then the messaging
the payments and then also the reviews
that is all done on share tribes posted
platform and that is the functionality
that share tribe is capable of but for
the user to come just in time I oh there
needed to be a little bit more than that
and improve user experience just that's
why I use WordPress in conjunction with
share truck now that you know a little
bit more about that I'm going to talk
about how I actually collect
subscription payments and manage that
process with that not technically being
possible on share tribal um when you
click on a or go to the subscription WWE
time iOS flash subscript in then you'll
notice that it's also on that WordPress
page so there's a few different pricing
options for these subscription packages
that we require to list or studio on
studio time and when you select one of
those you'll notice that domain is then
different than studio time about Ione
and also the listing stocks to do a time
die that is because I actually used to
charge me which is a great solution for
subscriptions and subscription
management you will notice on that they
take care of the hosting on that and
then also when someone selects many
subscriptions they are having the they
can manage it through their kind of
charge to you account that is not like a
you know it's not it's not a big ass or
someone to create an account with that
it's simple you know the name that the
kind of password generation which can be
the same as the other accounts so it's
really not been a big deal so far I can
leverage charge be effectively on the
studio time marketplace and it really
doesn't disrupt user experience also
something to mention is charge be
integrates with stroke so stripe is the
payment gateway that we use for
collecting the subscriptions with the
subscribe
not only to be this trophy for a
subscription you know sign up management
they also have a pretty cool dashboard
so I can see all the different KPIs key
performance indicators associated with
subscriptions such as monthly recurring
revenue animal current revenue churn all
these other kind of pretty cool KPIs and
analytics I can see through charge these
dashboard which I have since I used to a
platform also on stripe side I can issue
any charge backs refunds any of that I
can do through stripe which is of course
the payment gateway so now you know how
I use sheriff drive WordPress charge
week and stripe I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about hi effectively run this
marketplace and leverage these different
technologies together at one now I do
that by using slack you've probably
heard and probably also use slack with
larger teams or other team members but
since I wants to be a time myself I
actually have my own team funny enough
in slack but I use it for different
channels to create and send myself
different notifications for different
events that are happening real-time in
studio time so for instance in the
social channel I get a notification that
it's being mentioned on social so I can
tunnel a reply and also interact with
people on the social channels for
instance any signups new subscriptions I
can notification Tim slack for new
subscriptions so I get that teaching and
then I see that we got paid in a new
subscription and who that is and I can
actually then a automate an email to
them making sure that they get their
studio listings set up on the site I
also have created a web bug with that
using zapier in which is another tool to
then notify myself and send myself a
notification in fact that if this new
subscriber did not create a new listing
within a certain amount of time I can
send a notification so that way it can
reach
and send the second email to them and
make sure that they can get their studio
set up and don't have any problems with
that
that just really increases and enhances
the user and customer experience on
studio time so there's a few other
notifications that I see myself through
slack in a quick summary slack just
allows me to integrate multiple
platforms and in different different
technology solutions into one since I
don't have a custom kind of back-end and
you know API integrations I use slack is
that main integration point then I also
use zapier as I mentioned to Crate and
semi self web hooks for different
notifications that I need to be able to
run studio time on the go from my phone
no matter where I am or what I'm doing
so hopefully this gives you a pretty
good idea of how I've taken studio time
from the initial MVP to being the
largest online community of music
studios in the entire world and believe
it or not not using a custom built
platform but simply leveraging a lot of
different platforms and technology
solutions out there for very individual
functionality and different things that
I need and hopefully you can get a good
a good idea of how you can then use
these tools for your side project or
your startup hit subscribe so I can keep
making these videos and also comment
below with any questions to have I try
to reply to every comment comment below
and let me know what you want to hear
about or any questions you have about
taking your marketplace MVP to scale and
the different tools and different
technology platforms you can leverage to
do so thanks
[Music]